NoNotre panel se soit avec
MaMadeleine Blais Morin et notre
cocollègue Michel Auger et Alth.
BoBonsoir.
- - Bonsoir.
- - On va parler de l'Ukraine ac
dedes livraisons d'armes et
àà l'Ukraine et des sanctions
auau Russes.
CHCHRYSTIA FREELAND, vice-premie
miministre du Canada
- - Les membres de l'élite
fifinancière russe peuvent croie
quque leurs liens étroits avec
leles conseils d'administration
etet les yacth clubs d'Occident
leles protégeront. Mais ils ont
totort. Nous ne laisserons pas
leles Russes et les institutions
rurusses qui sont centraux dans
lala cleptocratie déchue
dudu président Poutine jouir de
cecette prospérité.
- - Madeleine a commencé avec vo
paparlons du rôle de la
miministreus.
ElElle parle Ukraine, elle parle
rurusse. Elle est de toutes les
rerencontres. Est-ce que le Cana
enen ferait autant si elle n'étt
papas là, Mme Freeland6
- - elle a dit qu'après l'annexn
dede la Crimée, elle avait été e
dede celle qui disait qu'il ne
fafaut plus mettre nos oeuvres s
lele panier de la Russie. C'est
popour ça qu'on a un commerce ac
lala Russie qui n'est pas
imimportante. Et c'est pour ça
ququ'on peut imposer des sanctis
sasans que ça fasse très mal à
l'l'économie canadienne. Ça ne
nonous coûte pas cher
imimposer ce genre de sanction
mamais en même temps elles sont
imimportantes si on veut
paparticiper à cette bataille
ququi peut être crucial pour la
vevenue du Canada dans l'ordre
momondial connaît actuellement.
LeLe Canada n'est pas une
susuperpuissance et il bénéficie
dede règles du jeu qui sont
clclaires et respectés.
SiSi c'est les pays qui ont les
plplus gros blocs qui gagnent
sysystématiquement, ça ne nuira.
MmMme Freeland en a une qui
reremonte à quelques années.
FiFigure marquante de la politie
cacanadienne. Quand voyait son
popoint de presse et
seses sanctions, où était Justin
TrTrudeau?
IlIl a participé à notre point e
prpresse.
- - Il y a un point de presse de
MmMme Freeland. Et on attend
totoujours Monsieur Trudeau?
- - Si le premier ministre n'est
papas là, c'est parce qu'il ne
veveut pas être la. Si Madame
FrFreeland esla c'est parce quee
cocommunisme veut. Il laisse
bebeaucoup de place.
UnUn moment donné il y a des ges
ququi commencent à dire : Justin
TrTrudeau a-t-il encore le goût
dedes premier ministre?
EsEst-ce qu'il prépare son dépa.
CeCes rumeurs ne sont pas pour e
gogouvernement. Il faudrait qu'l
sosoit plus présent mais jusqu'à
unun cerertain point, Madame
FrFreeland même si la sanction
rerelève du ministre de la finae
etet qu'elle a une connaissanceu
dodossier, et la presse que la
prpremier ministre n'est pas le
prpremier ministre.
IlIl y a une espèce de zone et e
MaMadame Freeland fait de son
prpremier ministre. Ce n'est pas
bobon niveau pour lui.
- - Je ne suis pas certain
d'd'accord. Si le premier minise
n'n'avait pas fait un pas de
prpresse une la presse celui de
MaMadame Phelan et celui de Made
FrFrazer.
C'C'est le point de presse ditea
étété porté à aujourd'hui pour
ajajouter du détail à l'émulatin
dedes rejets ukrainiens.
CÇa laisse des détails au
miministre et permet des questis
plplus larges.
PoPourquoi on rentre pas en
UkUkraine pour faire... comme ee
dedemande.
- - Protéger l'espace aérienne.
- - Exactement oui. C'est des
ququestions plus larges et c'est
plplutôt pour le premier minist,
lala direction et les détails pr
leles sous-ministre.
OnOn n'en est un peu beaucoup
paparce qu'on veut voir les enjx
popolitiques et la relève du Pai
lilibéral. Je dirais que Madame
FrFreeland en fait beaucoup mais
c'c'est surtout parce qu'il y a
dedes millions d'ukrainiens
CaCanadiens.
- - Elle fait parti aussi de cee
didiaspora. Elle a eu aussi de
paparents d'ukrainiens de la
didiaspora.
PaParlons de Jean Charest. Il
ététait au caucus du parti
coconservateur avec sa conduitet
soson fils.
JEJEAN CHAREST, ancien
prpremier ministre du Québec
- - Un sujet sur lequel,
jeje pense, qu'on va tous
s's'entendre, c'est l'importance
etet la responsabilité du parti
coconservateur du Canada envers
lele pays. Ça veut dire, un pari
popolitique qui est fidèle à
soson histoire et qui représente
chchaque région du Canada et qui
prprésente une vision qui est
trtrès inclusive pour l'avenir
dudu Canada.
- - Michel, il a pas dit il se
lalance encore dans la cause ou
papas. Mais quand c'est des
trtroupeaux comme il en a tenu,
ququi se passe?
- - Quand il arrive à hauteur ac
sasa famille, ce qui sera Qaïdat
y y en a plus personne qui en
didioute.
C C'est une espèce de pouvoir
atattention : oui le congrès aua
lilieu, au mois de septembre. Ms
enen même temps il faut que les
nonouveaux membres soient prochs
dadans trois mois avant le 3 ju.
N'N'est pas loin pour Monsieur
JeJean Charest. Il faut une grae
ororganisation. Il a gagné sur n
popoint. Monsieur Poilièvre a
gagagné sur l'autre. On verra sl
esest capable de développer en
trtrois mois une organisation
susuffisant pouvait entrer des
memembres au niveau il doit le
fafaire. Parce qu'on est d'accod
quque Monsieur Poilièvre gagnert
fafacilement actuellement. Mais
d'd'autres Monsieur Poilièvre et
popourraient avoir pas demain.
- - Les dates-butoirs sont
ininscrites ici. 19 avril date
lilimite pour le dépôt de : 3 jn
dadate limite pour l'impressione
momouvement. Et le vôtre celle e
seseptembre.
CoComme elle dit, Monsieur Jean
ChCharest attend de connaître ls
rrègles et une fois les règles
coconnues, il évalue sa joie à n
avavantage. À votre avis est-ce
quque ça lui dans le temps dontl
a a besoin pour avoir des mots i
vovont voter pour lui6
- - on a dit au début de semaine
avavant même que les règles soit
coconnues que Monsieur Jean
ChCharheika, même si Monsieur
PoPoilièvre gagnait qu'il y aurt
ququand même un vote.
JeJe pense qu'on s'attend à une
anannonce plus détaillée, avec
plplus d'attention médiatique.
JuJuste annoncés à Ottawa mercri
sosoir.  Il est dans la cause et
lala question devient: est-ce qe
lele maire de Brunton qui s'est
babattu contre la loi 21, rentre
dadans la course. Est-ce que
MoMonsieur Brown rendant la cau.
IlIl est bien ancré dans les
cocommunautés en Ontario est ici
auau travers le pays. Et Monsier
ChCharest et Monsieur Prendes
auaurait besoin de 200 000
nonouveaux membres pour pouvoir
gagagner la course à la cheffer.
SiSi Monsieur Brown selon dans a
cocourse et Monsieur Charest sot
enen avance, ces gens vont voter
popour eux parce qu'ils sont das
lala même philosophie.
CÇa pourrait l'aider. Si Monsier
BrBrown décide de ne pas rentrer
dadans la course, le travail de
MoMonsieur Jean Charest devient
bebeaucoup plus difficile.
- - Madeleine, Pierre Poilièvre
auaurait besoin d'une cause quie
tetermine plutôt. Hélas en régin
sasa faveur?
- - Pierre Poilièvre voulait jor
àà la stratégie du rouleau
cocompresseur. Il s'est lancé ts
trtrès vite dans la cause. Il a
fafait une communication entre s
sosociétés son commencement. Als
quque Monsieur sans arrêt utilir
unune stratégie en essayant de e
fafait désiré et en ne sachant s
ququand il se lance.
AuAu cours des prochains jours,.
mamaintenant qu'on connaît les
rrègles de la course.
CÇa va être une cause
inintéressante à surveiller mais
lala clé va se jouer dans les
trtrois prochains mois.
EsEst-ce que j'en serai incapabe
dede vendre des cartes de membr.
CÇa va se résumer à sa. Vendre
dedes cartes de membres en
atattente, au Québec, en Ontario
etet en Colombie Britannique. Là
ouoù ça va compter beaucoup,
etet au-delà de vendre les carts
dede membres, ça c'est mangé
nunuméro un, il va falloir qu'il
s's'explique sur des positions
papassées au sein du parti
coconservateur. La taxe sur le
cacarbone, le registre des armeà
fefeu. Quand il laisse entendre
ququ'il va peut-être se lancer
dadans la dernière course et qul
avavait changé d'idée, il avait
didit : il y a certaines positis
quque je ne renierais pas, qui e
sesera plus compatible avec le
paparti d'aujourd'hui, je
paparaphrase grossièrement.
CoComment il va convaincre le
paparti de rester uni malgré to,
sisi c'est lui qui gagne la
didirection du parti?
IlIl va falloir qu'il explique x
memembres du parti conservateur.
- -  Il est en train d'avoir des
apappuis qui sont surprenants.
QuQu'on note Michel que pensez-
vovous du fait qu'on entend le
miministre Savannah qui pense
dedevenir un assez Monsieur Jean
ChCharest se lance. Madame
ThThériault aussi. Qu'est-ce que
çaça veut dire tout ça.
- - Au parti conservateur, c'est
unun d'anciens libéraux. Il faut
ququ'il trouve des appuis
coconservateur. Donc les amis
dede Monsieur Jean Charest, c'et
nonormal mais va falloir aller
chchercher d'autres. Il faut qul
exexplique cela aux conservateus
popour que ceux-ci le trouvent à
çaça. Il y a des choses qui
sosont... pas ample régime des
ararmes à feu. La taxe la carbo,
cece qui a fait la perte de
MoMonsieur O'Toole pratiquement.
IlIl va faire cette petite chos,
etet qu'elle amène des membres i
crcroient que perçut une taxe sr
lele carbone est acceptable.
- - Il y a déjà des attaques es-
cece qu'il y a soit ça
apapparaissait. Une députée qui
apappuie Pierre Poilièvre qui a
mimit sur Twitter :
leles montres Monsieur Trudeau t
MoMonsieur Jean-Charles pour
momontrer à quel point Monsieur
ChCharrin n'est pas assez
coconservateur.
- - Les attaques du côté de
MoMonsieur Poilièvre les depuis
unune semaine. Il veut vraiment
dédécourager Monsieur Charest de
rerentrer dans la cause. Il y a
bebeaucoup de conservateur danse
cacaucus. Monsieur Poilièvre ena
2626 et il y a beaucoup de dépus
dede l'Ouest qui veulent juste
chchoisir un gagnant. Qui veulet
ququelqu'un avec plus de
mamaturité que Monsieur Poilièv.
QuQui veulent quelqu'un qui va
ununir le pays, pas juste la bae
coconservatrice, qui va pouvoir
alaller chercher des appuis dans
leles provinces, au Québec et sr
OnOntario.
C'C'est ça comment expliquer dea
rerencontre. Monsieur Jean-Chars
auaurait dit aux députés de
l'l'Ouest qu'il sera ouvert à
l'l'idée qu'un pipeline traverse
lele territoire québécois.
C'C'est un québécois qui pourrat
vevendre un pipeline de l'Ouest
ququébécois.
LaLa taxe sur le carbone je ne
pepense pas que ce sera une gros
enenjeu comme beaucoup le pense.
IlIl y a une très forte base avc
MoMonsieur Poilièvre qui s'attae
àà la taxe sur le carbone. Une
trtrès forte e base dans le pari
coconservateur à l'instant tu ne
vovois pas... c'est insupportabe
popour d'avoir la taxe sur le
cacarbone. C'est la base des
coconservateurs et de ses 200 00
memeant. Il y a beaucoup de gens
ququi ont voté au parti
coconservateur à l'automne
dedernier. Ces gens sont beaucop
enen Ontario et qui pense que la
tataxe sur le carbone va être l.
EsEst-ce que le prochain premier
miministre enlèverait vraiment?
IlIl y a des gens qui veulent
jujuste choisir un gagnant. Et
MoMonsieur Jean Sahar est à plus
dede chances de gagner dans une
élélection que Monsieur Pierre
PoPoilièvre.
- - Ça présente les enjeux.
EtEt lui qui se défend dans tous
ceces enjeux